[Musique]
jean-mi vous étiez dans la rue proche de
chez vous tout à l'heure que vous avez
été agressée olivier marchal et mes
cailloux devons mener les enquêtes
vous allez devoir trouver qui a agressé
jean michel maire
oh
top de mes 2
si vous trouvez la taupe à la fin avec
le concours d'olivier marchal et demie
cailloux ou partir à marrakech mais
selon la jaxa
sinon la taupe partir à la raquette
jean-michel mais à ce que vous avez une
idée de la personne qui vous agressez
jeu
j'ai les deux tours doit être au doute
mais elle est là on serait plutôt de ce
côté là d'accord pas
est ce que vous voulez et m'éliminer
déjà des gens il ne serait pas là où je
pense que j'ai mis une pierre d'accord
est ce que pierre il peut pas courir et
puis pof be so à la fin ce que tu fais à
la fin et isabelle peut le faire encore
et je les mines aussi valérie ah bon
pourquoi ce que les gentils les uns peut
s'inscrire mont athos n'ai pas écris moi
j minina alors olivier et michael tu me
vois alors j'ai me geraldine ouais bah
pierre ouais
valérie et isabelle d'accord
titoff s'il a pu le il a pu physiquement
non je pense que c'est en milieu
d'après-midi milieu de prix je pense que
c'est parce que c'est jean-michel je
pense qu'il s'agit de deux individus de
type féminin non c'est vrai pourquoi
remet le doute dans la façon de
sautiller de la façon de jeter le saut
il ya des trémies nos féminines goût
auquel taminelli un peu féminin ont
peut-être qu'on pourrait faire passer un
casting de petits sauts en l'air on
élimine benjamin jean teuf et gilles et
maxime non 2 3 merci mbokani
c'est qu'on avait peut-être les
chauffeurs
j'ai l'impression qu'elle a simulé je
pense je pense c'est maxime maxime vous
dites qui dit oui à vous a dit maxime
serait plutôt maxime maxime maxime
gagnon regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les braves ont pris part à marrakech
fouet
d
[Musique]